we are the guardians of the Republic
that's that's how we really see
ourselves and it's important that our
country sees us that way also I'm Dave
Rubin and joining me on the Rubin report
today or two u.s. combat veterans one a
former member of the US Congress and one
a former MMA champion Colonel Allen West
and Chad Robicheaux welcome to the Rubin
report thanks today I am glad to have
you guys here because as I mention to
you right before we started we haven't
done enough generally on military and
veterans issues and and all of those
things so we're gonna dive into all that
talk about your nonprofit and why you
guys are here together and all of those
good things but first off what made each
of you want to go into the military
colonel I'll start with you well for me
it was a family tradition you know we
just celebrated the 75th anniversary of
d-day well my father fought in World War
two he was a corporal in United States
Army he initially started in North
Africa Sicily Italy and that's where he
was wounded rena supplied dispatches my
older brother was a marine infantryman
and vietnam wounded a caisson and at the
age of 15 my dad challenged me to be the
first officer in our family so i went
through high school Junior ROTC in
Atlanta what did fifteen-year-old Island
West think about that 15-year Allen West
wanted to you know follow his dad's lead
and I think that that is why positive
strong role models male role models so
important in the black community because
my dad gave me a direction and a goal
and objective so on 31 July 1982 at the
University of Tennessee in Knoxville he
was on my right shoulder my mom was on
my left shoulder and they pen 2nd
lieutenant bars on me and now today his
grandson dad passed in 1986 but his
grandson is a major United States Army
so that's four generations and how many
years did you serve 22 long time yeah
Chad what about you well uh three
generation Marine Corps family my father
served as a combat marine in Vietnam as
an infantryman and my son is now in
Afghanistan right now put a third
anglich oh yeah supporting the Georgians
in Afghanistan so and I was a marine as
well when they deployments to
Afghanistan so I uh my father being a
marine I suffered with a lot of things
that we help alert with at a foundation
and he came home he's
angry guy a lot of alcohol physical
abuse and so I grew up in a very
dysfunctional home I had a brother as a
year older than me and we were about 13
and 14 years old we decided we were
joined a military to escape that life
and so we both started running and
swimming and teamed up to prepare for
that kind of that goal in life and
unfortunately about a year after that my
brother was shot and killed and so it
put me in a very what I had left of a
family dissolved it put me in an extreme
isolation and in that isolation I just
continued to focus towards that goal
have been in the military and when I was
17 years old I'm in a Marine Corps crew
named sergeant Brown who I hadn't even I
wasn't going to graduate high school
live I was living on my own by that time
and I wanted to be in some type of
Special Operations and I expressed to
him you know what I wanted to do and he
told me about being a reconnaissance
marine so I set my sights on that and so
a Marine Corps for me Joey at 17 years
old was a clean slate of life and ran
your chance and at that young age I was
aware enough to embrace it and it's been
an amazing part of my life yeah what do
you think that regular people that don't
serve who love America you can see I've
got a giant American flag in the control
room we've got another one right over
there we've got the constitution and the
declaration independence in there what
do you think that regular Americans
should know about you guys people that
serve that maybe we don't know what one
I don't I don't think people often
realize how special it is for someone
who serves in the military currently we
only have a half a percent 0.5 percent
of our population the United States
serves in the military and he o stands
in the gap not just to protect the
freedoms that we have in America but to
protect the interests of others around
the world to stand up for people that
can't stand up for themselves that's one
of things always loved about the
military and I think people don't
understand is the fact that we do serve
as strength for the world not just our
nation able to protect you know these
people around the world that don't have
the ability to defend themselves yeah
we're gonna get into some of the the
policy parts of that what do you think
we should know about you guys that maybe
we don't I think the most important
thing and you know my Christian faith is
very strong in my life when you go to
John chapter 15 verse 13 where it says
that no greater love has an
the man that he will lay down his life
for another then also in Isaiah six and
eight when Isaiah is there with the host
of the Lord and and there saying whom
shall we sin who will go for us and
Isaiah says here am I send me we have to
understand that the freedoms and
liberties that we have here in the
United States of America is that we
because we consistently raised
generations of these young men and women
that are going to continue to give that
last full measure of devotion and that's
why Abraham Lincoln talked about the
increased devotion that a nation should
have for those in the Gettysburg Address
and so when people come up and say thank
you for your service I mean that's all
fine and well but I think the real
tribute and the real honor to people
like Chad myself and all the generations
that have worn a uniform is we want you
to understand why we took an oath to
support and defend the Constitution do
you guys think that there is a little
rebirth of that happening right now
because it's not a coincidence that I
put the flag there in the Constitution
and the Declaration of Independence I
don't think it's a coincidence that as
people have watched me sort of evolved
politically and talk about these things
and pride in the country and those
things I don't mean blind pride I mean
you know really understanding where we
came from and where we're going
I do see a rebirth of that now are you
seeing that I am and I said that's just
just recently at a speaking event I
think when people turn on the news they
think you know the country has lost its
way but that's just I think those
allowed and voiced and allowed few when
I go around the country and speak about
the work that we do and and supporting
our warriors I get to witness firsthand
a grateful nation of Americans who are
patriots they love their warriors they
love their country and a and they would
kind of have the same views that you
have that it's a special place and and
it's a sacred place that we need to
uphold the values that we have in this
nation yeah I know you have no love lost
there the mainstream media but do you
think that it partially is that that
they've sort of gone so bananas and I'm
making it seem that America is so evil
and we're patriarchal and racist and all
all these ridiculous things that
eventually you push good people to say
whoa whoa whoa yeah no we're not and
that's actually good no and it is I
don't think that you know is so
interesting you and I were talking
off-camera how you said five or six
years ago you thought I was a nut
and now we're sitting here having a
great conversation yeah and I think all
of us if we really understand the
objective truths about this country we
come to realize what America really is
it's a beacon of Liberty freedom of a
democracy that's why people come here
when I lived in South Florida I never
saw anyone get on a boat to go to Cuba
right okay no one is leaving they'll
leave they don't leave Guatemala El
Salvador Honduras to go to Venezuela so
you know this is a very simple thing so
when you have someone like a Governor
Cuomo the stance of a says oh you know
America has never been great tell that
to those men who's 75 years ago landed
on those beaches in Normandy and jumped
in you know the night prior tell that to
your dad and my older brother who fought
in those jungles in Vietnam tell that to
my dad
go to his you know final resting spot a
man that fought for this country when
this country did not afford him all
those rights and privileges it did
others mmhmm yeah he wanted his son to
still be an officer in that exact same
army that's America
that's what it's all about Dave so how
do you balance that which I think we
obviously all agree with with that also
we do make mistakes
also we're flawed also depending on
political leadership there might be
times when you're really all gung-ho
about all of our policies and sometimes
you're not yeah I mean I think as a
nation we are gonna we are like you said
you're not you know what people leaving
to go to Cuba I mean we have a line from
Guatemala to to San Diego people to come
here and there for a reason it's not
just for free health care and in college
you're coming here because about this
land of opportunity it still isn't and
and I prayed always well it will be but
we're not going to do things right all
the time we're not gonna have leaders
that are always gonna make the right
decisions but I believe America as an
institution this great the great
experiment of America is something that
still stands true and and it's the
reason why you know the world looks to
books towards us and America as a nation
and as a military the strength of it
that makes the world a better place what
do you think it is fundamentally about
the military that allows it to keep
America strong despite having
administrations that can wildly go in
different directions I mean just look at
the last two those are the policies
Bhama versus the policies of Donald
Trump are
vastly different but we haven't had a
coup you know the military is still
functioning still doing its job what
what is where does that strength come
from well if you go and you read the
Constitution you know the founding
fathers talked about moving toward a
more perfect union so we're not a
perfect country but we understand that
we have a foundation we have a
fundamental you know values we have a
rule of law that enables us to move in
that direction that's how we continue to
amend ourselves and that's the
interesting thing about military dave is
that we don't take an oath to a
political party we don't take a note to
a person we take a note to that document
that you know I'm carrying right here
that unifies us as a nation that that's
our rule of law that's our standard and
so our military is focused on that and
nothing more and we are the guardians of
the Republic that's that's how we really
see ourselves and it's important that
our country sees us that way also so no
we're not gonna go in and throw a coup
because one administration to the others
but you know maybe there are gonna be
some orders that are not exactly ethical
that we will stand up and challenge and
that's why we have these generals and
that's what we expect them to do as the
members of the Joint Chiefs of Staff but
we we take that oath to the Constitution
and I think that's important so let's
talk a little bit about your service
specifically so you served in
Afghanistan you served in Iraq you know
Afghanistan seems to me to be the
weirdest military adventure or war
whatever you want to call it at this
point because it's the longest ongoing
war that we've ever had in the universe
it's still going on now people seem to
be very confused as to why we went in
the first place why are we still there
sort of break that down well I think
that I feel a lot clearer more clear
about Afghanistan or why we went there I
mean great September September 11th you
know planes were flown into World Trade
Center and it was done so by the Taliban
and we had a we had an obligation to go
and hunt down Osama bin Laden in the
Taliban that were responsible for it and
part of that meant to align with the
north alliance which would have been a
Massoud would have been the leader of
the North Alliance which bin Laden
clever
we killed at the same time assassinated
at the same time and so as we went to
Afghanistan we had to you know not just
go after one person but we had to had to
go the the infiltration of the
Afghanistan by the Taliban occupation of
that and so going after going after the
Taliban meant a occupying of Afghanistan
not to overtake the country but to
eradicate Taliban Anette and obviously
that's still going on 20 years later my
I would never thought after eight
deployments there my son we are there
fighting the Taliban right so is that is
that a failure of our policy is there an
inconsistency between administration's
there what do you think that is let me
know yet think at eight years for eight
years of doing this of that twenty years
the military was completely handcuffed
they were there their cut cut resources
manpower and and rules of engagement
that were not favorable to our troops
and that's you're talking I'm talking
about them bomb administration at the
cost of many American lives and uh and I
truly believe that the administration is
responsible for that and luckily now the
rules of engagement have changed and
we're able to go after and more
offensively go after the Taliban and I
think we're having a more effective
footprint there however I think
Americans should understand that we're
not there as a in the same capacity we
was in the early days we were there to
support the AMA the Afghan National Army
we're there to support other allied
forces such as my son right now is
assigned to the Georgians who were out
doing combat patrols and presence
patrols
so we're there more of a support and
advise capacity right now yeah and and I
think even with my son Aaron loved him
to come home but I think we belong there
in that capacity to support advice and
help help for nations because these
nations like they and they they can't if
we left they in a Afghan National Army
to do this themselves they would they
would fail so that actually is a good
segue to talking about Iraq because one
of the things that happened Iraq you
served in in Desert Storm but after this
last Iraq war you know there was this
big debate when do we when do we leave
and basically Obama took us out with
just announcing the day we're going and
they were having free and fair elections
there was actually the beginnings of a
democracy there now you could argue that
we maybe we should have never been there
place you could argue that we had to
leave no matter what you call those
things but democracy was spreading and
then we left it now it's gotten much
worse so actually first why do you talk
about a desert storm just in general
because that's that's the Forgotten one
now because people only think about this
the second round you know it's it's
incredible that that has happened and
one of the committees I sit on is to
establish the National Desert Storm War
Memorial in Washington DC and so because
it has been forgotten but it was an
important bridge from us coming from
Vietnam to once again reestablished that
respect to regard for our military but
there will never be another Desert Storm
no one is ever going to take on the
United States of America and a wide-open
desert of conventional warfare you know
two of the best training facilities for
our military is right here in California
two to nine of Palms and then also the
National Training Center we are experts
in open desert warfare and the Iraqi
army learned that in 96 short hours but
the real thing was that we built a
coalition we you know held to the
objective that we were going in on the
United Nations mandate it was to get the
Iraqis out of Kuwait but what you have
seen metastasized now is a world that
understands you don't fight the United
States of America you know up front
face-to-face now you have this
ideological war against Islamic jihadism
they don't wear uniforms they don't
openly declare themselves they are
non-state non uniform religious and
that's what you know Chad had to deal
with in Afghanistan and even after I
retired I was in Afghanistan for
two-and-a-half years as a civilian
military advisor down in Kandahar we
have to we have not done a good job of
understanding this modern battlefield
understanding this enemy that we're
facing even Russia you know when they
went into the Crimea they didn't go in
as the Russian military they went as a
paramilitary force and you see what
they're doing in Ukraine China when you
look at what they're doing all over the
globe they do say that this is our
strategy the one belt one road but they
are covertly doing things that we don't
understand China is in Venezuela as a
matter of fact Iran the number one state
sponsor of Islamic terrorism in the
world but you know Hezbollah is not out
there really
you know declaring a in their estate or
what have you and I said oh they are
flying their flags and let it fly the
flag but you know Hezbollah doesn't have
a country and so I think that we the the
the incredible thing I got to be at the
tactical level and then also I got to be
at the strategic level having sat on the
House Armed Services Committee and just
the same in Vietnam we lose
strategically we don't lose tactically
on the ground it's at that level with
the policies and everything where we
make some really dumb decisions you know
rules of engagement not understanding
the enemy their goals and objectives
that you know it filters down and we set
our warriors up not for success and I
think that's what we have to learn what
do you make of the fact that George HW
Bush this sort of the famous moment
where he decided not to go to Baghdad
not to topple Saddam the first time
around he was obviously under pressure
for more of the neocon types to take
Saddam out at that point the irony being
that we left Saddam and then we just his
son ended up going in yeah 15 years
later so what was it like to be there
when that decision it was incredibly was
made or not made depending on you want
to look at it yeah because I was in the
1st Infantry Division and we were the
ones that had secured Safwan airfield
for the peace negotiation talks to come
in and we just sat there that night and
said man ok so major lieutenant colonel
when you think we'll be back because any
time you fight half-measure warfare you
have ongoing residual consequences I
mean you look at the Korean War you look
at the Vietnam War the last time we
fought a total war was World War two
when we wanted the enemy to capitulate I
mean they sign a document of surrender
we don't have that today so you you
believe in the power of doctrine
basically that you're gonna do it you
just you got to do it right absolutely
absolutely and and that's what Carl von
Clausewitz talked about he said War is
about imposing your will upon another
you don't still do half will now with
Desert Shield Desert Storm we would have
lost credibility though if we had
continued on but I think that we did not
do a good job of decorating the complete
capacity and capability militarily of
Saddam Hussein because we had to their
Republican Guard divisions just right
ahead of us we could have taken those
guys out and maybe brought him to an
even better position at the table but do
you think the military brass wanted to I
don't know these are the people there I
think I think the thing is we kind of
felt we didn't seal the deal and we kind
of knew that eventually come back but
even more so we could have done better
with the Kurds I really feel that we
continue to kind of you know
back-slapping occurs when they are so
pro-american and and they so want to be
an ally of ours and and what we have
done with Isis couldn't have done
without the Kurds yeah is that just one
of those situations where Iraq really is
three countries yeah and it's like all
right we could I suppose we could impose
some sort of partition and give the
Kurds what they justly deserve that then
we'll probably make turkey rain hell on
them and a bunch of other things you
know well turkey is not exactly our
friends on earth one if you go back
post-world War one the sykes-picot
treaty when the great powers of England
and France went and they just divided
the Middle East up arbitrarily just the
same as you saw in Africa you know they
didn't pay attention to tribal
allegiances and what-have-you they
created artificial nations the lines
actually look ridiculous you know if you
really look at them they have the shapes
and all of these things there so I think
that there's an opportunity now for us
to maybe look at how can the Middle East
be restructure I mean the Kurds are the
nation's largest ethnic group without a
homeland and and I think that they have
suffered
you know from increased persecution I
think that they could be more friendly
to you know their Syrian Christians the
Chaldeans who are also persecuted and so
I think that's where you you know we
don't do strategy in long terms we do
strategy and election cycles day yeah
and you can't win that's just the part
of this that probably never changes they
almost screws up everything and it does
grew up everything because you can't win
against people that are thinking of 50
and a hundred years cycles so so with
all that in mind if we look at
Afghanistan today and now you're saying
some of the rules of engagement have
changed we're doing things a little more
effectively how do we eventually not BNF
is there any road that you can see to
getting us there died I don't think
there's any successful road as a
complete full withdrawal I think I think
we need we probably will maintain a base
there maybe Balcom Basin and continue to
support in this advisory role so I have
to say this my capacity in Afghanistan
was much different than the conventional
troop I was a I was a Force Recon marine
I had the unique opportunity try out for
a JSOC the Joint Special Operations
Command Task Force and so the capacity I
worked in was I didn't live on a base I
lived out with Afghan people I was
embedded with Afghan people and we're
still being closed and and so I lived in
their homes and a dinner with their
families and what did what did they
think about you guys well they look
that's that this is a point they love
the fact that America was there because
they had been truly oppressed by the
Taliban and and so I got at first when I
first went I was I deployed like every
other warrior after 9/11 we were going
there to right the wrongs of 9/11 that's
a very patriotic cause that's what
motivated us but very quickly I went
from that to understanding what these
people had endured from the Taliban to
see their hurt and their pain and their
what what the Taliban have done to the
women and and the little kids little
boys and little girls and and seeing
this and hearing about stories and
understanding this it really turned my
heart from this patriotic sense of
retaliate for 9/11 - these people are
pressed and we need to be there that
home these people and that's where I'm
torn today because I still have a heart
for these people I mean I I lost Afghan
brothers like in combat that uh and so I
still have a heart for these people and
and can imagine I couldn't imagine I was
there for the 2004 election I remember
sitting in a living room everyone's like
a Super Bowl party everyone's tune in TV
because John Kerry and and Bush's as and
everyone these guys be these people have
this food everywhere they having this
giant party I never seen anything like
no one in the United States excited for
a presidential election like this was
and and when Bush won they were so
excited because they were so terrified
that if Kerry won he would withdraw the
US troops what would happen to them they
know they know what'll happen to them if
we leave and and so it really changed my
perspective on being there again as a
father now and with
I'm like that's my son blowing there it
made me ask these questions all over
again but I do believe that we don't
belong there in a in a conventional
capacity but as us as a support and
advising role I do believe we don't so
with that in mind what is a sound policy
what is a sound foreign policy that you
can do some good you can try to build
the not nation builders just yeah but
try to set the seeds of democracy and
freedom which we were doing in our act
which we're doing in Afghanistan but
make sure that we don't become the
imperial Empire forever mired down so so
what do you think just broadly because
we're started talking about this at a
personal level from your perspective
what do you think broadly just a sane
foreign policy well that's the key thing
it should not be about nation-building
it should be about you know strike
operations is about having a force that
is able to make sure that these Islamic
jihadists are not able to have a defined
sanctuary and base of operations and
what we have been doing up to this point
Dave we've been playing whack-a-mole and
you can't win playing whack-a-mole so
what we need to be able to do is instead
of having this massive forward deployed
military you have a power projection
platform and so you have you know AB
Algrim you have a base you know
somewhere close in Iraq where you can
launch troops very quickly and you have
a strike operation you hit a critical
capability capacity of the enemy and you
know then you pull back but you stay in
that very basic region to let them know
that we can quickly respond once again
and that's what you just saw when we
brought into the carrier group into into
the the Persian Gulf area to stand up
against Iran to say that we do have a
credible military deterrent so your
foreign policy is worthless unless you
have that deterrent and and they teach
you in Staff College about the four
elements of military army and national
power diplomatic informational military
and economic and I think that what we
have to do is continue to use the
diplomatic the informational the
economic means first and foremost but we
have to show that you know
push comes to shove we can do this if
you're not willing to so with that in
mind do you regard the Obama red line in
Syria as just like the biggest the
biggest blunder of things I remember I
was a lefty at the time you can watch
videos of me on The Young Turks I was
saying we should not be there I was
saying I don't that they've got to take
care of it though or the regional actors
have to take care of it let Turkey help
some of these people like I did not want
anything to do with that I was
completely anti-war but then once Obama
said the red line thing I was like all
right well if you if you set the deal
here then you have to follow through do
you view that as just I don't know has
there been a worse blunder of let's say
just said well if you lose all
credibility whatsoever and then people
see you as a joke I mean when you come
on you say Isis is just a JV team then
you know you're saying that I'm
dismissing this thing when you deal with
someone like Kim Jong Un's saying we're
gonna have strategic patience well the
guy keeps shooting off rockets and
missiles and everything like that so you
know compromise appeasement negotiation
things like that you know there are
people in the world that the only
understand strengthen Mike and Chad and
I we've seen those type of people we
understand that anything else is deemed
it's weakness so when you draw a red
line then all of a sudden you say well
run really my red line it was everybody
else's red line you know leaders take
responsibility and that's what you know
you failed to see then now we have
someone that has come in he's saying
okay rules of engagement got to change
you generals you're going you take care
you do what has to be done we don't hear
about Isis now they still exist as an
ideological enemy but they don't have a
territorial integrity you know you have
China that is now saying you know what
is going on here I mean we just had the
run of the mill for all of these years
Republican or Democrat president now
something has changed North Korea the
same thing even Russia is starting to be
concerned so I think that's the
important thing is you know you have to
be able to come out with that stick when
it is required when it is necessary and
if you create a void like President
Obama did in Iraq
someone's gonna fill that void that's a
law of physics so I think we got some
hints as to what Cornel West thinks
about Trump's policy you know foreign
policy what do you think
well I think you know all four areas
that you're talking about particularly
in economic sanctions right now I mean a
lot of people you know continue that
every time the president says something
that he's gonna impose these impose
tariffs or or do economic sanctions
people laugh and mock him but it turns
around weeks later you know but then so
many I think he keeps pushing these
these things both military military
strategy and diplomacy and economic and
and you seen him win in these areas and
uh you know this could be becoming hard
to doubt the president yeah
what do you think about his
decision-making abilities when it comes
to selecting certain people so I
remember like when Bolton got put in
yeah it was like all right now Trump's
going all neocon and the base which was
very anti-war was very pissed and I
remember sort of thing well it's like
that doesn't mean you're going neocon
because you bring a guy like him around
it actually means you're bringing
somebody around that is known as a
threat that kinda keeps the enemies
going we don't and then you have trump
who says anything wait a minute combo
here is a guy who we think likes war or
who does like we're let's say or however
you want to phrase that plus a guy like
trump who says whatever he wants now we
don't know how to react basically and
that is the thing no one understands
that decision cycle so people are
completely off-base they don't know what
it's going to come out you know in the
morning their Center I said okay what is
it going to tweet now and in the marine
corps because I did three years on
exchange with the Marines they call it
the OODA loop and what you want to do is
to be able to get inside the enemy's
decision cycle and you want to
completely throw them off off their
their game and that's what President
Trump has done you know you know you
think he really gets that at a military
level there's a New York thing they
might be well I think it's sort of I
always say it's more like he's just kind
of and I don't even mean this I don't
even truly don't even mean this
negatively necessarily but he's kind of
just a crooked New York businessman but
you got to do a lot of stuff within the
hill a lot of stuff we got to do a lot
of stuff within that to make things
happen because the whole system is out
of whack and see a normal politician is
gonna follow what everyone says okay you
gotta do X you know to do y I got a
doozy I mean they got the set battle
scheme or whatever and he just has
completely selling that playbook out and
folks aren't used to that he is not
predictable
and really on the battlefield you don't
want to be predictable and this is a
Bala this is an economic battlefield
this is a diplomatic battlefield it's a
military battlefield and he is just
completely out maneuvering our major
adversaries China Russia Iran North
Korea in the world in a better place
because of it right now do you think
that's empirically true but I mean if
you listen to the media it sounds like
you know any moment World War 3 is gonna
happen where something's going down with
China Iran is gonna get the bomb this
that the other thing but do you really
feel that there's empirical proof that
actually things are safer or more stable
well I mean we have I mean what's north
North Korea going to do what's wrong I'm
gonna do we have no you know we no way
to predict what they're going to do but
I think the actions that the president
and the administration has has proven
that they they are responding to I mean
North Korea is responded in a way that
you know we've never thought they would
respond to with the relationship
ron has back down Mexico who's you know
really taking advantage of a the United
States over many many years it's finally
coming around I mean these these things
may seem extreme because people weren't
used to it and and but I think they're I
believe the world is a better place
right now yeah what do you think of
think about this day the president said
I do not want to see people dropping
bombs on innocent women and children and
he bombed Syria now from a tactical
level you know you looked at the battle
damage assessment it was not really a
big thing but the fact that he took the
action that was the the the most
important thing I mean when Iran starts
to maybe do a little saber rattling he
doesn't you know get back on his heels
he says send a care of battle group and
and and let's show them that you know
we'll go toe-to-toe you're not going to
see sailors on a river and assault boat
on their knees at gunpoint mm because of
the Iranian Revolutionary Guard Navy
that ain't happened right which we saw
which we saw and every American you
talked about the Flay every American
should have been incensed that we had
sailors who surrendered instead of
fought and while on their knees at
gunpoint to the Iranians yeah well that
must be why Trump wanted what within two
months of being elected he dropped that
mother
of all bombs and people were like oh now
he's he's going all Warhawk but your
argument would be he did it because it's
like you show a little bit of erratic
behavior you put your shield strength
too and that keeps these guys on their
heels
[Music]